UTIN'S
ON DISSENSIO SNSUP
PLUS AND CALLEPUTIN'S WAR  CNN
GOVERNMEOF S.
HE WASD
AND CETOT GUEST IS NNGER TO
PUTIN'S AVY-HACS ONCE THINTHON
BIVEN WANGW BO "FREEZ
FOR MANY, MAOU IN
E T YOU T HAS CHANGED,T
GEORGIA, IT WALID,ER, ITTOOK THE
T WAYI, IT HL FRONTAL
FOR
AFTER 70TY.
I HASAYS BEANE'T NOW IS ONDINGT
SAFETY.DICTATORS AROUND FOR2 YE.
MONEPE ANGRY
WID HE HAS WATCH
NEIGHNG
COUNTRIES INAK
OVERTHRN, IN
BELAS TH
THIS IS A WA,
HE'S BASICALLY SRTWA THE RUSANA
ONT NGF HEPOWENTSDS UPOITO JAILZ
REO HIFEARS AND
TH'S
>> AND IN VENE OE FOREIGN ENTIO
>>NNOU LOO CHART
GEPPROVAL RATINGS GO
IMEA APPROS
D NO THING
IT'SUSS ALMOST LIKE
CHHE STARTS R L RATING DO YOU T
THERELOT OFNTENT >> HOW COULDHU
POWER UNTIL NO AND 1,000
OPLE AROUND HA
TRILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
RUIASTATE.
A TRLIAND THON BT , EDUCATION,
ROADSEES
INSTEAD IT WENT TOHTVI
HOW CAN ANYONEE HAPPY
N >> WHED PROGRAM
ONA'ESBUSINESSMAN AIR THE FIRSTS
SAY, DECADE
PRSYONFUND NOW WORRIHA THAN
HE HAS THESE VISIONSF INXT O, H
INTERESTCAUSE LOOKRK ON AS HAVII
BUI  KNOW, EY, BEINGZED. SOMET E
IF YOU TAKE THATSIS, THASATH HE
E GREATNESS OF , BUW CAN ANYONET
MONEY FROM THEEOOWLETELY AND
E A DESPERATE FRD OF BEING KILLL
UT THE PEOPLE
>> DO ECONOM
O?ULD DONUTRE O>> W, IT DEPEND
DISEASE WHETHER YO  WHETHT GOES
IF W  SMALL OE
SANCTIONS,LY, BEFORE HE INVADELL
D DO
SOG, HE MI ENT LCMA DECISIO
VACHANGIMIND
VER SES, NCK NOW ARE
VERY SPL TO COMPLETELY
LURVHEFINCRE EXECUTE TE OI
AND NATURAS NU
>>N,OU A
BUSINESSMAN.
ISY, YOUNOE UT
RUSSN ENERGY S
THEY DO?
OU ARE EXACTLY RIGHTSO T COSTSL
EXECUAU A
BILLIODOSI TO BUY BULLETS TO KLI
RETE A BIT.
THON'TT A LOWHICH  PRICE.
AOR TWO
TT COOPE ON NWOD
THIS WHOLE THINGHELD BE NSIDERE
>> THE
YO HS A FRIEND
HAHERE XT?VITEMY NE TO RSI
I' THEE TOADIMIR PIN B YSA TO RN
WITHOIWO  SENDI'TOO D TED.I SHOA
ASSASSINATION ATHE IS
SAY OU THE CUSTODY OF THO
N SS, I'M STRUCKE
LE
I MEP -- G , THEYTO POISON, TY
10,  Y AH SUCCSFMANYIDENTS BUT N
LLAY IT MAKE AFERENCE?
>>L, -
THIS WHOLE THING AYEL
TO BE CHAO THEREATION IS THAT  '
LECAN IMS
OTD IT'S HAPPENING ILO